foreign
to a
to the Qualcomm Institute
California Institute of
telecommunication and information
technology and most importantly the
Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination
I'm Sheldon brown the director of The
Clark Center and I'm glad you all could
join us for this uh mid-summer musing on
on our place on what our place in the
universe is
might be
and uh and it and you know when
you know this just kind of came together
out of the Confluence of the visitor
coming to town and and some recent
results that one of the scientists in
the Clark Center has been recently
involved in and
um and it connects with uh another uh
writer in Residence at the Clark Center
work that he is done and looks into
about the questions of
of what the universe itself might
actually consist of
and um as we're doing this it reminded
this this whole subject of the
Multiverse um reminds me uh reminded me
very much of something
um that isn't uh this has a bit of a
deeper history literary history to it
and that is a story
um by the Argentinian author Jorge Luis
Borges called the library of Babel
um which is a story written in 1941 and
and
um I don't know if any of you are
familiar with it but um just give you a
bit of a synopsis of this story and
you'll and as the evening unfolds you'll
kind of see the connection I think to
the subject but um in this story uh
Borges describes this vast Library
containing all possible books which
would consist of 410 pages and any
arrangement of 25 alphabetic symbols in
this in the in the in the book and in
this Library there's no two identical
books but every possible book written in
that format is theorized to exist and
Borges creates a structure of this
Library
that's these hexagonal hexagonal shells
and he stipulates how many how many
shelves are in each room how many books
are on each Shelf
and then ends up describing the
um this is the setting and subject and
and what this is what societies develop
in this context as they seek to
understand the nature of this Library
they're in
um in fact the statement that it
contains all possible books is a is a is
a theory about what the library is
um so they create these kind of theories
to try to understand what their universe
is and then what it might mean
um and I'll just read you maybe a couple
little quotes from this story
when it was announced that the library
contained all books the first reaction
was what unbounded Joy all men felt
themselves the possessors of an intact
and secret treasure there was no
personal problem no world problem whose
eloquent solution did not exist
somewhere in this in a hexagon
at the same period there was hope that
the fundamental mysteries of mankind in
the origins of library and time itself
might be revealed those profound
Mysteries can indeed be explained in
words and if the language of the
philosophers was not sufficient the
library would surely possess the
extraordinary language required to
explain these things but this unbridled
hopefulness was succeeded by a similarly
disproportionate depression as the
generation spanning investigations could
hardly turn up a book that was anything
more than gibberish
in in in his lifetime of searching the
story narrator found only two phrases of
coherency one was combed Thunder and
another is the plaster cramp
so
the story sets up this evocative
scenario I think which has been
reinterpreted over the years
first as a metaphor for the process of
writing how meaning could possibly be
created out of what is otherwise just an
infinite possibility of nonsense
the second is it was seen as a prescient
tale about the nature of information and
the creation of the internet
so you often found this this story being
rolled out throughout the 90s and in the
early 21st century as people were really
understanding the magnitude of what this
new information system was
now we start might see this story and
its narrative as a reflection of some of
the latest discoveries and theories
regarding the origins and the
possibilities of the universe itself and
um
and you know and so out of this you know
the fact that
in this Multiverse we consist in you
know Ponder this for a moment there's
this exact same lecture going on right
now except in that one I'm wearing a
yellow shirt
kind of mind-blowing I know
um
so tonight we're going to hear from
three people discussing the idea of the
Multiverse
from perspectives of current scientific
theory and with a nod to its literary
merits
in part this is due and and part we're
having this also is it's it we're right
now at the Clark Center we're also
hosting the Clarion science fiction
Writers Workshop
and um and so participants from that
Workshop are here with us tonight and
um
and just give you a bit of a mention
about what Clarion is it's a it's an
intensive six-week summer program
focusing on the fundamentals particular
to writing Science Fiction and Fantasy
stories and it's um
uh it's one of the Premier training
grounds for aspiring writers of science
fiction fantasy and horror
right now the instructors are Anne and
Jeff Vandermeer and tomorrow they'll be
giving a reading tomorrow night at the
mysterious Galaxy bookstore so it's a
great chance to go and meet with them
um
I also want to thank uh have some thank
yous for people who helped make this
event possible I want to thank ViaSat
who is the founding partner of the
Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination I also want to thank our
patrons and founder Orbitz orbit members
Cindy and Mark dankberg Stephen Sue Hart
and Diana Dugan
um
mention a couple an upcoming event on
August 11th we are going to be having
another one of our sci-fi flick events
where we're going to be screening
Gattaca and we'll have some people in
conversation about Gattaca Larry
Goldstein the director of the Sanford
Center for regenerative medicine
was one of them and so check up on our
website and Facebook pages for further
information
so let me introduce the speakers that
we're going to have tonight I'll
introduce them all at once and then
they'll each come up
um after they'll each give about a 15 to
20 minute talk and then we'll have a
panel discussion with them afterwards
and so remember your questions for them
for when we get into the panel part of
the discussion
um so we have with us Dr Andrew Friedman
who's a National Science Foundation
postdoctoral fellow at MIT and a
visiting research scientist at the MIT
Center for theoretical physics
before coming to MIT he did a PhD in
astronomy and astrophysics at Harvard in
the department of astronomy
and received a ba in physics from an
astrophysics from UC Berkeley and his
background is mainly in observational
cosmology including infrared
observations of supernova which can be
used to measure the expansion history of
the universe as well as Cosmic
acceleration and dark energy
he's currently working on several
theoretical cosmology projects including
devising fun experiments that leverage
cosmology to help test fundamental
physics
uh he's very and he's interested in the
intersection between observational
astronomy cosmology philosophy of
science and the philosophy of cosmology
so Andrew will start and then we'll hear
from Professor Brian Keating who's an
astrophysicist here in the UCSD
Department of physics
he and his team of 21 students and
post-docs develop instrumentation to
study the early Universe at radio
microwave and infrared wavelengths he's
authored over 100 scientific
Publications and holds up and holds a
patent he received his BS from Case
Western Reserve University and his PhD
from Brown he did postdoctoral research
at Stanford and an NSF postdoctoral
fellow at Caltech before coming to ussd
in 2004. he's received the 2007
presidential early career award for
scientists and engineers
and at from at the White House from
President Bush
and for a telescope he developed at the
south pole research station called bicep
he co-leads a collaboration operating
the polar bear research telescope in the
uh takama desert of of Chile and he's a
trustee of the national museum of
mathematics a member of the Clark Center
Advisory Board a member of the math for
America board and the San Diego Air and
Space Museum
and then we'll hear from David Brin
who's a writer in residence for the
Clark Center
um and um and then is also a scientist
and best-selling author but he's mostly
known for his Clark Center writer in
Residence I'm sure
um and uh in his future oriented novels
include the postman and Earth his uplift
uplift-based Hugo Award winners include
star tide rising in the uplift War
um this the postman you might remember
is turned into a major film in 1998 by
Kevin Costner and is sure to be the
subject of an upcoming Clark Center
sci-fi flick Knight
bran is also known as a leading
commentator on Modern technological and
I would say socio-cultural Trends his
non-fiction book The transparent Society
won the freedom of speech award for the
American Library Association and his
newest novel existence explores the
ultimate question billions of planets
may be right for life even intelligence
so where is everybody
so we'll hear from each of these in
order and then and then Professor
Keating will
moderate and participate in a panel
discussion amongst them so Dr Friedman
oh
[Applause]
one night I'm sorry one I I missed my
best slide if you could just give me the
uh
a quote to leave us with a quote from
Borges to start
all right thank you so much it's uh
fantastic to be here today to talk about
uh the Multiverse which is definitely
one of the most exciting and
controversial ideas in all of science
and some of these ideas may definitely
sound like they're straight out of
Science Fiction but believe it or not
the idea of other universes is not only
not completely crazy it's actually a
logical extrapolation of our best
understood theories of physics and
cosmology
that doesn't mean we we know for sure
that other universes exist
but it does mean we know enough that we
have to take these ideas seriously
and so I'll be joined tonight by Brian
Keating and David Brin as discussed and
hopefully we can paint an
interdisciplinary picture uh behind the
Multiverse so I'll start by giving an
overview of some of the theory behind
the different levels of the Multiverse
that people are talking about today
Brian will follow up by talking about
some of the leading experimental
evidence we have that makes us take this
picture seriously and David will
conclude by talking about how human
beings might fit into this picture
and to be fair the entire topic of the
Multiverse could take up an entire
University level course
so we're just going to give you kind of
a taste very very much for the tip of
the iceberg about what we can cover in
about an hour
and I'll draw heavily upon the ideas of
my MIT colleagues Alan Guth and Max
tegmark and they couldn't be here today
but they have a good excuse they're
currently Trapped In Another Universe
about 3000 miles east of here also known
as the Multiverse Institute of
Technology
and I I say this in part because we
recently had a chance to all three of us
give a talk at the same panel at the
American Astronomical Society conference
in Boston on a special panel entitled
Multiverse observation in theory
and you know here we are at the the
biggest astronomy conference in the
world talking about parallel universes
so what this tells you is that these
ideas are becoming more and more part of
the mainstream people are regularly
publishing articles in the in the top
physics and philosophy journals on this
stuff so while some people still hate
the idea of the Multiverse and there are
many many Skeptics this is by no means
the you know universally accepted in the
scientific Community
fewer and fewer people are dismissing it
just because they say it's crazy
so it's great to be here at the Clark
Center and I actually only only heard
about this this place through David
Brynn and Brian a few months ago and
it's it's kind of amazing that that a
senator devoted to the human imagination
actually exists this seems like the the
kind of a place that would only exist
inside of a science fiction novel
so you know being here kind of makes me
feel like I'm somehow turned into one of
David's characters
but in any case
if these gentlemen were still with us I
think they'd get a real kick out of
these ideas which are all about
exploring the limits of the possible
so the the question at stake is in some
sense the biggest question of all how
big is the world how far does reality
extend
and it's interesting that to human
beings living just a few centuries ago
the Earth itself but might as well have
been infinite
and today we've kind of come full circle
because the leading theory of modern
cosmology is very much consistent with
us living in a very large space which
could be infinite of which we can only
access a finite part
and and reality could be even bigger
than that
so one Arc of the the Multiverse story
is a so-called copernican principle the
idea that human beings don't occupy a
special preferred location in the
universe uh each time we think we reek
some some limit where we're right at the
center we find that we're kicked out of
that preferred perch so we now know that
the Earth is not at the center of the
solar system the solar system is not the
center of the Galaxy our galaxy The
Milky Way is just one of a hundred
hundreds of billions that we can observe
in the part of the universe we can see
and other universes are just sort of the
latest chapter in this story
um but but the copernican principle can
definitely be taken too far I happen to
believe that human beings are very very
important in the cosmic scheme and life
itself is very important you know aliens
aside we're the only beings that we know
of that can talk about things like the
Multiverse and think about how we might
fit into it
so as a rough outline
um I'll discuss some of the various
levels of the Multiverse that people are
talking about today and I'll very much
follow the scheme developed by Max type
Market MIT because I think it's one of
the most clear ways of of putting forth
the ideas although uh this this list is
by no means exhaustive Brian Green in
his book talks about nine different
levels I'm only going to really talk
about four and when Brian and David and
I were discussing this we brainstormed
and came up with about 20 or 30
different different ideas so this is
just uh the tip of the iceberg
so I'll discuss the first level which is
basically Parts beyond what we can see
beyond our so-called cosmological
Horizons and maybe universes perhaps
living inside of black holes I'll talk
about uh different universes produced by
the theory of cosmic inflation and Brian
will talk about some of the best
evidence we have for for this I'll talk
about the many worlds of quantum
mechanics
and even universes with other laws of
physics and David will hint at just a
few of these in his talk
and but since the evidence for at least
the first level
is is very very
strong indirect evidence it's not a
question so much about does the
Multiverse exist it's a question of how
many levels are there
and these do get more and more
speculative as as you go down the chain
but believe me there are even crazier
ideas out there than these
so we have very very strong evidence
that the part of the universe that that
we live in is about 13.8 billion years
old
here is a little baby picture of the
universe this is a so-called Cosmic
microwave background radiation the
Afterglow of the Big Bang which is like
a snapshot of the universe about 380 000
years after the big bang
here's an image of some of the most
distant galaxies we've ever observed and
every single splotch of light in this in
this picture is is a Galaxy
and but because light travels at a
finite speed we're not seeing objects as
they are now but as they were when light
left billions of years ago so in this
sense a telescope is is basically a time
machine
so when you combine the finite speed of
light with the finite age of the
universe there's a limit to how far a
light can travel since since the Big
Bang
and you might think that that limit is
exactly 13.8 billion
light years but in fact it's it happens
to be a little bit farther than that
because you have to take into account
the fact that the Universe has been
expanding all along so we actually think
the universe is not only expanding today
but actually accelerating and speeding
up a next expansion due to so-called
dark energy this unknown cosmological
anti-gravitational Force making galaxies
move farther and farther apart from each
other
and so it turns out that the the
distance light can travel since the Big
Bang if light was emitted right after
the big bang is just arriving at us
today
those objects now are about 46 billion
light years away
so if you're willing to take seriously
the idea that perhaps maybe you know 100
billion light years in that direction
there's a Galaxy
then you're already talking about the
first level of the Multiverse Parts
beyond what we can see and this picture
is actually very much the standard view
of modern cosmology
and ultimately it would be it would be
crazy if space just sort of stopped
right there if there was an edge to
space
um but there are relevant boundaries one
thing that's interesting about the
cosmic acceleration is that
the expansion of space itself can
actually outrage light this is actually
allowed in relativity and what this
means is there are places that are so
far away that you'd be kind of traveling
upstream and if you try to reach them
you could never reach them even if you
traveled at the speed of light forever
and this is I think why even though
these these other parts are really part
of the same larger space it's why they
really deserve to be called separate
universes because they're causally
inaccessible in principle at least as
far as we understand things
so just a little bit about Cosmic
inflation it's our our leading theory of
the early Universe cosmology developed
by Alan Guth at MIT and others and the
idea essentially is that there was an
exponential period of expansion of space
in the first instance of cosmic history
and what this does is it solves the
number of cosmological problems which
would otherwise be ridiculous Mysteries
Brian will talk about this a little bit
it makes a number of very very risky
testable predictions about things we can
observe let's say things in the
microwave background radiation
but in addition it predicts that space
is much much larger than the part that
we can see because if enough inflation
occurred to solve these problems
then
it's guaranteed essentially that the
Universe extends beyond the part that we
can access
so any evidence for inflation
is really really good indirect evidence
for at least this first level of the
Multiverse so what do these other
universes look like the idea is that
they would have the same laws of physics
as our universe but they would have
different constants of nature different
things like values I'm sorry but the
same the same constants of nature the
same values for things like the speed of
light the amount of dark energy the mass
ratio of the proton electron
but what they would have is different
initial conditions
as illustrated by these slightly
different baby pictures of the universe
and therefore different outcomes
so the distribution of galaxies would be
different slightly in each of these
universes and maybe one of them is a
place where a planet like the Earth
formed and another is a place where it
didn't
so there may be other kinds of uh
universes that are beyond what we can
see that are practically right next door
in our galaxy you've all probably heard
of black holes these regions of space
and time that are so gravitationally
distorted that if you fell in past the
so-called Event Horizon you could never
Escape
and we have very very strong evidence
that black holes exist at the center of
essentially every Galaxy we've observed
very very large black holes billions of
times the mass of our sun we have very
strong evidence that smaller black holes
the size of stars exist there's probably
a black hole within 100 light years of
our position right now
but what we don't know is what happens
inside of black holes we don't know
about black hole Interiors our our
current theories the physics are not
complete enough to describe that
so
we don't know for example if you would
be destroyed by a so-called firewall of
higher energy radiation as you pass
through the Event Horizon maybe you'd be
spaghettified and stretched into an
infinitely thin Strand and obliterated
by the differential gravity of the tidal
forces for a small black hole but for a
large black hole where the tides would
actually be less maybe you'd maybe you'd
survive maybe you would actually find
yourself in some other part of
space-time so for example we don't know
if some are all of black holes or
actually so-called wormholes these
connections between distant parts of
space and time
and
so maybe you know if if that's if that's
possible if you fell into a black hole
and you might end up somewhere else you
might ask maybe we're already inside of
a black hole so this is actually not as
crazy as it sounds people are actually
really seriously considering from a
theoretical perspective
the idea that an accelerating expanding
universe as seen from the inside might
be sort of dually described by a black
hole as seen from the outside
and some people take this idea really
really seriously including Lis Mullen
with his theory of cosmological natural
selection he envisions a network of
universes within universes produced by
black holes and the essential idea here
is that the universes that would sort of
do best in this scenario are the ones
that have the parameters of nature that
would allow them to produce the most
black holes produce the most progeny so
this is kind of a darwinian view of this
picture and the most speculative claim
of this idea is that the same parameters
that actually lead to most black holes
being produced are also the same ones
that are required for life to exist
so
although this this particular Theory I
think has some problems and and may be
wrong in some of the details it's a very
very interesting speculative suggestion
about how you might think about
darwinian processes on cosmological
scales
so coming back to inflation
after it stopped in our universe
the expansion proceeded according to
kind of a more leisurely Pace even the
cosmic acceleration that we're
experiencing now is is very very small
compared to what happened during
inflation we think
but it turns out that just because
inflation stopped in our part of the
universe
it's actually very hard to build models
where inflation only happens once
it's the kind of a situation where
if inflation stops let's say in a little
bubble right here it's probably going on
somewhere else this is the idea of
so-called Eternal inflation and as you
might guess these these universes these
are different in character than what
we've talked about so far these form the
sort of ingredients of the second level
of the Multiverse but these places are
also so far away that we couldn't reach
them even if we traveled at the speed of
light forever
so they're separated from us causally in
the same way that even the the first
level ones are
so some other theoretical ideas that
lead us to take this picture seriously
come from String Theory which is our
current best candidate for a theory of
so-called quantum gravity which would
combine our understanding of quantum
mechanics or theory of the subatomic
world with gender relativity which
describes our theory of gravity on the
largest scales including cosmology
and in order for string theory to work
you actually need extra spatial
Dimensions so we're all pretty familiar
with the the standard you know three
spatial dimensions in one time Dimension
you all successfully made it to this
room at this particular time so you're
good with those four dimensions so so
what what were the other six or seven
look like the idea is that uh why don't
we see them one idea is that they're
actually very small and very curled up
very tiny if you could zoom in to space
time
you would see them
these are sort of illustrations
um two-dimensional projections of what
could be these larger you know more
complicated six-dimensional spaces
here's a fun little movie of a cross
section of these kinds of objects but
the idea is that each of these different
ways of making a shape like this is a
different way that a universe can be
and it turns out that as far as we know
it now there are literally astronomical
number of different possible ways of
making these extra Dimensions curl up
and so this describes the so-called
landscape of possible universes
according to string theory and the
connection to Eternal inflation with the
bubble universe is is that
Eternal inflation would be the physical
mechanism that populates
the landscape
of possible universes in Eternal
inflation
so
for the for the second level of the
Multiverse the idea is that you'd have
the same laws of physics
but in this case this is the case where
we actually think you'd have different
values of the dimensionless parameters
of nature things like the mass ratio of
the proton electron things like the
amount of dark energy
and so the idea is that
any evidence we have like from a CMB
for inflation
is indirect evidence for this this level
as well
because it's actually really hard if
inflation happened once for it to only
happen once
and and this also explains another
mystery
this is the mystery of so-called
fine-tuning for life
so it turns out that to the best of our
understanding
if you look at these parameters of
Nature and you change them just a tiny
amount it actually makes it very very
difficult for life to exist as we know
it so for example if you increase the
amount of dark energy the universe
expands and accelerates so fast that
galaxies never form
so if you think galaxies are a necessary
prerequisite for life like us that's bad
news if it turns out that if you tweak
other knobs you can make it so no stars
are reformed or no planets ever before
you can even make it so that there's no
periodic table there's no chemistry no
stable elements so these are all kind of
pretty crucial prerequisites for Life as
We Know It
and this leads to the mystery well how
is it that we have you know the the
right values that allow for our
existence
so were we just lucky
were those values perhaps chosen by some
force or some intelligence
or perhaps if the Multiverse exists
if there are many universes with
different values of these parameters it
makes it more plausible maybe even
inevitable that at least one would be
just right
this leads us into the the very
controversial anthropic principle
essentially this this idea states that
the physical constants must be such to
allow our existence if there's only one
Universe this is clearly a tautology
this just says we just because we exist
but if there are many universes with
different values of the constants of
nature then this argument has logical
explanatory and predictive power so for
for example let's say you consider
something like the value of the distance
between the Earth and the Sun you could
ask a question why is it that this
distance is exactly right to allow for
water to be liquid on the surface
isn't this amazing this is incredible
mystery
but we're actually not that surprised by
this especially because we now know that
there are literally
thousands of other planets that we've
discovered probably billions of other
planets Even in our own Galaxy
and they have a distribution of
distances between the stars and planets
so there's an ensemble and of course we
have to find ourselves living in a place
that's consistent with life like us it's
a very similar argument is well why
don't we find ourselves living in empty
space
because most of space is empty well that
just doesn't work for human beings
and crucially the logic is exactly the
same for the Multiverse
so Switching gears to a different level
of the Multiverse from quantum mechanics
level three this is the view that's
percolated most into popular culture the
idea of parallel timelines the idea of
what if I had made a different Choice
how would my life have turned out
this is the idea that the Observer or
the universe splits with every Quantum
event this is illustrated by this fun
little film reel and you might recognize
Schrodinger's cat here
this this is the idea that reality sort
of takes on a branching structure
and
this this might seem like it has nothing
to do with the other levels we've
discussed so far but in fact some some
new ideas very speculative ideas
suggests that maybe this level is
actually unifiable with it with the
first two levels within a cosmological
context so it's possible that the many
worlds of quantum mechanics are actually
really out there someplace far away in
space
but
it's also possible that there they might
actually be in a sense right on top of
us
we don't know very we don't know very
much about this question this is why
it's a really interesting place to be
working
so what evidence do we have for the mini
world view of quantum mechanics
well some people think that the many
Worlds View provides the best
explanation for what's actually going on
in experiments like the famous double
slit experiment if you have a beams of
photons sent through a screen that has
two slits it'll form this standard
Quantum interference pattern this wave
interference pattern
and but the amazing thing is that if you
do this experiment and you send single
photons through one at a time
the interference pattern still builds up
so this this leads to the question what
was it that the photons were interfering
with
well they're behaving exactly as if
they're they're interfering with other
photons maybe we should take seriously
the existence of these other photons
which essentially would be photons and
other universes as described like
quantum mechanics
another idea comes from the idea of
quantum computers these are computers
that could perform calculations
incredibly faster than equivalent
classical computers if these are built
and they perform these calculations
then the question becomes where were the
computations performed
it seems very difficult this is not an
airtight argument but it seems difficult
to understand where the computational
resources are
so one idea is that perhaps you could
think about this as the computation
being shared amongst many universes
the problem with this picture is that
there are literally dozens and dozens of
interpretations of quantum mechanics
more than even ideas of different kinds
of levels of the Multiverse that I've
seen
and the other interpretations at this
stage essentially give the same
predictions as the many Worlds View so
we need a tiebreaker we need a new
theory for perhaps quantum gravity that
will allow us to modify these
interpretations so they actually make
different experimental predictions and
are therefore distinguishable
so but I will say that the many worlds
view is still consistent with everything
we know
about quantum mechanics
so
so far we've only talked about levels
with the same laws of physics the most
speculative level is the idea that maybe
universities with different laws of
physics might be okay these would be
described by other kinds of mathematical
structures as illustrated by these fun
geometrical shapes here why would you
take this seriously there's this
interesting question about why math
works so well to describe the physical
world Eugene wigner a Nobel Laureate
called this the unreasonable
effectiveness of mathematics in the
physical sciences
so one answer to to why math seems to
work so well is that maybe the world at
its core is fundamentally mathematical
maybe there is a mechanism which we
don't quite understand yet by which
mathematical existence actually gives
rise to physical existence this is
clearly the the most speculative level
we've discussed so far but trust me
they're they're much amongst crazier
ideas out there
so is is this is this science or not
so it's not an understatement to say
that these ideas represent kind of a
battle for the soul of science
at least in this corner of theoretical
physics Skeptics of these theories think
that if you go down this rabbit hole
it's the end of science as we know it
how can you over make any any testable
predictions when it comes to Regions
which seem inaccessible in principle
forever
so rather than rather than taking that
attitude and kind of giving up I
actually view this as a challenge and an
opportunity to think of new and clever
ways to try to test these kinds of ideas
it's it's really important to remember
that parallel universes themselves are
not a theory they're they're predictions
of specific theories like inflation like
string theory
and in order to test the theory we don't
need to test all of its predictions only
some of them
and but but you have to take the theory
as a coherent whole you can't just pick
and choose which of its predictions you
take seriously
you have to take them all seriously
until a better Theory comes along maybe
there'll be some other better theories
that come along that don't have a
Multiverse as the predictions but that's
not the current state that that we're in
so in summary
some people still hate the Multiverse
but I think a lot of this has to do with
just purely aesthetic judgments I I
admit that I find these ideas fun cool
and interesting and and I I think okay
what has to be true about the world
beyond what we know in order for these
ideas to be testable
and I don't I don't say that I believe
in the Multiverse with 100 certainty but
I think that as long as we are trying to
move forward towards testing these ideas
then we're still doing science
and quantum gravity has some pretty
interesting suggestions one idea is that
space and time might not be fundamental
quantities but might actually be derived
from more primitive Concepts such as how
how Quantum mechanically entangled and
connected to regions are so it may be
that some places which naively look
really really far away according to
general relativity might in some sense
actually be very very close to us so
um as soon as you consider things like
wormholes for example you're considering
ideas that would allow what seem like
inaccessible regions to be accessible
so
overall the first level of the
Multiverse is pretty pretty solid and
uncontroversial it's just the idea that
the part of the universe we can see is
not everything this is the standard view
of modern cosmology
if you accept the logical extrapolations
of our best physical theories inflation
string theory
quantum mechanics general relativity
you'll take seriously level two
if you think that quantum theory makes
the most sense in the many worlds
perspective he'll take seriously that
level and if you think that mathematics
is fundamentally
discovered and not invented then you'd
be willing to take seriously this level
and who knows who knows how many more
levels there are in any case this is a
really really fun thing to think about
it lies kind of right at The Sweet Spot
between philosophy of science and
theoretical physics and it's it's
certainly a fun and exciting time to to
be a scientist at least in this universe
thank you very much
[Applause]
so next we'll hear from Brian Keating
talking about some of the experimental
evidence for inflation
and we'll follow that up by hearing from
David about
putting up putting this all into a human
perspective thank you
okay
can uh can you guys hear me
okay so I am the token experimentalist
on the panel tonight so I brought with
me my own baby universe
I hold in my hand an actual universe
and in this universe
Sheldon's not wearing a shirt at all
it's the most popular one of all
okay so uh and he gave an excellent
introduction to these deep and mystical
uh theories that seem to be uh both in
Vogue and and quite quite speculative
but at the same time may have tremendous
tremendous impact just as The Big Bang
Theory was a pejorative the name itself
is a pejorative but is now accepted by
all but a few people in in certain parts
of the country
um as being as being exact exact
description of nature so now maybe it's
not so crazy to think perhaps we do live
in a Multiverse
so I want to talk about this Andy showed
this slide this is a famous woodcut from
the 1500s when they just had invented
Photoshop and what it what it depicts is
this ancient Quest cosmology is a very
easy science to do in one sense because
you can do it with just your eyes and
your brain and in fact that's how early
humans did it that's the oldest science
people looked up and wondered and this
depicts this this character looking back
in space and as Andy said your eyes just
like a telescope are time machines so
you can look back in space you're
looking back in time so things that are
far away from us this artist who
conceived of this wood cut was
conjecturing what they might look like
now where this looks not too dissimilar
from some of the Escher paintings and
and wood cuts that we saw at the end of
Andy's talk so how crazy is it really to
speculate about such things and it's
really as I said one of the oldest
quests of humanity here's a more modern
depiction of it um that I've stolen uh
and and this depicts uh sort of a very
crude space-time diagram that shows
things today down here and then in the
past this beach ball uh flattened out
and laid flat as as if you're God
looking down on this region of the
Multiverse and the preceding the
preceding Epoch to when these uh most
ancient photons left uh the the
primordial plasma that that Epoch we
believe uh is called inflation I'll talk
about that because the hypothesis is
that if inflation occurred as Andy
mentioned in many models of inflation it
still is continuing it still exists and
it have so-called Eternal inflation you
cannot shut it off in that case there
may be an Infinity of universes and in
fact this diagram may be wrong there may
be no dawn of time and we may be back to
the old Aristotelian and pre-arist
Italian notion that the universe is
infinitely old and that uh baby universe
is perhaps spawn cyclically into and out
of existence I'll spend a lot of time
focusing on discoveries that we made
using this image and images like it with
our telescope at the South Pole called
bicep and how we infer from the
properties that we see here what this
Epoch might have been like and then The
Logical extrapolation that you must make
is that if this uh if this occurred if
this inflationary Epoch occurred then
perhaps something like the Multiverse
must also be mandated in some theories
of physics both from a coupling of of
the inflationary high energy physics of
the early universe and also things like
string theory as Andy mentioned
this has attracted a lot of attention uh
from worldwide organizations this is on
the front page our Discovery with bicep
two the so-called space ripples of the
Big Bang Smoking Gun so I always I
always like this this headline down here
from The Economist sounds like some guy
just suddenly sees the start of the
universe wow you know if you're looking
in one oh I saw it I saw it it's like a
meteor
um and then of course the the um the
best the best newspaper in all of
science is of course the UCSD Guardian
which is a little bit more circumspect
and and very calm in their notion they
said UCSD scientists prove inflation
Theory well that's pretty awesome I I
don't think you can even prove a theory
in physics let alone the fact that we
did it all by ourselves which we did so
I'm going to talk to you about this and
I always say it's a mystery it's a it's
a Mysterious Universe in which we live
there's a mysterious Galaxy not too far
from here we can buy David's books but
there's also a mysterious Multiverse and
so I don't want you to ever come away
especially I see a lot of young people
in the audience and that's wonderful
people I want you to come away with the
notion that there's way more to do than
has been done and the people that are up
here really haven't even scratched the
surface and it's your job to come up not
just with the theories and the
conjectures but actually follow through
with it learn the math learn the science
learn the physics build the experiments
travel these distant places that's what
I want to inspire you guys to do and and
even we have some some older people that
could be inspired to do that too
so I always say it's a mystery and the
Mystery like all great Mysteries you can
maybe phrase in the form of a murder
mystery and I'm going to lay out a few
different of these bullets uh and and
I'm going to hope to hopefully motivate
the fact that there is evidence that
inflation occurred and then following on
from Andy's talk that perhaps if
inflation occurred there too uh
therefore also did the Multiverse the
Multiverse somehow follows from this
explanation uh but I'm going to leave in
a little wrinkle at the end so I want
you guys to stay tuned I'll wake you up
for the end so I'll talk about the scene
of the crime where we go uh and what the
early very early Universe was like I'll
talk about our crime lab where we built
a forensic tool to appraise what the
yearly Universe must have been like and
then the so-called Smoking Gun as the
New York Times front page decried that
we seem to believe is indicative of this
inflationary explosive expansion of
space-time and then perhaps the jury's
still out there's still some controversy
about our results and even some some
very interesting conjectures for the
future
so just a very quick uh diagram this is
probably the most technical diagram I'll
show this is a slide that our
collaboration
put just to demonstrate the major
features of cosmology and and one slide
it's very difficult to do but
nevertheless it starts with a big bang
at least our portion of the Multiverse
or in the region that we when I was a
kid there was only a universe okay so so
I have to get used to it just like when
I was a kid there were nine planets but
then people like Adam bergaster and
others came along and killed off Pluto
uh
and so and so now I have to always
correct myself that there's only eight
so we talk about the Big Bang as being
the local origin of as Andy said this
observable universe that we can detect
that's roughly 40 plus billion light
years across that instant is called the
Big Bang time equals zero if you set
your watch and then roughly a trillionth
of a trillionth of a trillionth of a
second after that came this violent
expansion of space-time called inflation
and then after that things in events are
listed here that are a little bit more
prosaic in terms of their impact but but
um but they're all observable relics
they all produce relics that we can see
today even if they're not in the form of
light we can detect the processes the
fact that we observe elements today
Light Elements like helium and hydrogen
those are relics left over from The Big
Bang very little hydrogen can be can be
formed outside of Laboratories so what
we see is residual primordial evidences
this is Trace forensics from The Big
Bang itself
when the protons combine with electrons
that were around since the very
beginning then the the cosmic microwave
background or CMB is formed and this is
as famous three Kelvin background that's
depicted here when a globe of the sky
flattened onto onto this beach ball
and uh this depicts what you'd see with
your eyes if your eyes were sensitive to
microwaves and you looked out at the
night sky you wouldn't see
constellations you wouldn't see stars
planets or galaxies instead you'd see
fluctuations in the microwave
background's temperature as intensity
and its polarization and that's this
Epoch here and so what we're trying to
do is use this image that we've made and
other groups have made of the of the of
the very early Universe 380 000 years
after the big bang take this image and
use it as a type of film okay so it's a
little bit strange to think about light
being a film and nevertheless we have to
think about it in that way we're
attempting to expose waves of gravity on
these photons okay so probably half the
audience doesn't remember film but but
half the audience does
um so so a film was this ancient thing
that we used to use 10 years ago to take
pictures and it would expose light here
we're not exposing light or exposing
gravity waves of gravity gravitational
radiation from the inflationary Epoch on
this background so it's as if we're
looking at this beach ball and what
we're trying to see are not the
temperature of fluctuations themselves
but distortions and ripples this thing
is wiggling like a ball of jello and
those those Wiggles are imprinted by
waves of gravity those waves of gravity
are produced during the epoch we call
inflation
we built a telescope to do that and in
doing so we uh we we were Guided by the
fact that we've confirmed many of the
predictions of inflation Andy mentioned
a few I'm not going to go over them but
inflation is one of the most well-tested
if not proven theories despite the
ucsd's guardian headline
um it cannot in some sense be proven but
even even to the extent that we can
understand ways to falsify it it's been
it's been passed with flying colors so
we can't say that we've proven it unless
we can rule out every one of an Infinity
of possible Alternatives but in this
case we have so much credulity in the
model that it behooved us and and myself
to invent this experiment to go after
this unique signature of inflation
called gravitational waves that produce
so-called b-mode polarization so we're
looking at this pattern of microwaves
they have polarization properties
associated with them just like polarized
light reflects off the ocean surface you
can use polarized sunglasses to see it
and we're looking back at this pattern
to see waves of gravity exposed from the
very earliest instances after the big
bang so what is the CMB I want to show
you this uh just kind of cartoonish
glimpse so if you go out into low earth
orbit and you looked and your eyes were
sensitive to microwaves this is what
you'd see an amazing depiction the
beauty the you know the grand Elegance
if you're a religious person this is the
face of God it's so beautiful uh no this
is what you'd see to First approximation
you'd see nothing it would be this
uniform boring puke orange glow that
your eyes would detect no discernible
pattern from this is the so-called three
degree Kelvin microwave background
signal this is the primary tool that
Precision cosmology has been used to
extract the parameters of the very early
Universe now if you take away the flux
the the average level that you see in
each Direction on the sky you're left
with these fluctuations like on this
beach ball
and this is quite this is quite a
exhilarating map to see an image like
this was called by Stephen Hawking the
like looking at the face of God
ironic because he's a devout atheist but
nevertheless looking at these images
looking at these patterns we've refined
our understanding of the global
properties of the universe its age its
mass its energy it's uh it's it's
possible future Evolution it's just
incredible to think of everything we've
accomplished just with this and now
we've endowed it with another observable
call that's polarization which I'll talk
about briefly so it's discovered in 1965
so I always say it's the last great
discovery in astronomy from northern New
Jersey I'm a New Yorker so I'm entitled
to make fun of New Jersey
and it was discovered actually
serendipitously back when this was the
entire internet so Steve and and Sue and
and Cindy are here from viosat so this
used to be the entire internet it was
one satellite that communicated around
the entire Earth you bounce signals off
of uh even even more slowly than you
could do with a with an old 300 baud
modem and you'd be able to communicate
with it but when they launched it they
found they couldn't get rid of this glow
in the background that's seem to come
from all directions and that of course
turned out to be this three Kelvin or
2.7 Kelvin microwave background
radiation so that was its Discovery they
won the Nobel Prize for this in 1978 and
uh in the old days I usually say to
people you know if you tune your
television to a UHF station that's no
there's no signal local signal you would
get static on it but nowadays no kids
know what static is okay YouTube never
gets static
um so uh but about one percent of the
static on an old-fashioned CRT type
monitor would be from The Big Bang
itself
so the the orange glow that you saw
originally is the background radiation
it's three Kelvin then there are tiny
little fluctuations predicted by our
late colleague art wolf who was at UCSD
predicted that there should be
fluctuations in the microwave background
only two years after its Discovery quite
astounding uh prediction and that was
borne out in 1992 when the Kobe
satellite measured the uh these imprints
these fluctuations in the microwave
background for the first time and that
was uh later awarded the Nobel Prize in
2006 to George Smoot and John Mather and
those fluctuations those fluctuations
led us to believe that there must be
some Force responsible for the
fluctuations on the largest scales in
the universe just to give you an example
of how small I say these are large so
the the microwave background itself is
three degrees Kelvin subtract away three
degrees Kelvin you're left with
fluctuations that are about one part in
a hundred thousand how big is a part in
a hundred thousand well the surface of a
bowling ball if you map the surface of a
bowling ball and compared it to its
average radius the fluctuations are
about a pardon 10 to the fourth or a
pardon ten thousand meaning that the
surface of a bowling ball which most
people consider pretty smooth is
actually much much rougher than the
surface of the last scattering surface
than this image would be if it were
depicted as a bowling ball again not my
bowling ball because I'm a terrible
bowler has a lot of dents in it so the
question is where do these fluctuations
come from and the inflationary model has
posited that these fluctuations come
from Quantum behavior in the early
Universe in the fabric of space-time
itself so what are we trying to do
we're trying to take this image this is
now just a purple and blue cut this is
the actual Kobe image of the full Sky
laid out flat again and we're trying to
understand from this image that we see
that dates to 10 trillion seconds sounds
like a lot it's 380 000 years after the
big bang we're trying to infer from that
what did the universe look like a
trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second after the big
bang 50 orders of magnitude
extrapolation from the physics of 380
000 years after the big bang to
essentially right at the beginning of
time so what would that be like doing in
more human terms in a more human scale
so imagine uh you look at this creature
over here you biologist here will
recognize this and and if you do
recognize it please come to Gattaca
event on August 11th this is what you
look like a thousand seconds after you
were conceived okay this is called the
blastocyst it's roughly 100 to a
thousand cells assembled into this
little nice little soccer ball package
and if you were trying to extrapolate
what this image looked like by looking
at say this this handsome devil here if
you were looking at him
and you're trying to extrapolate from
this image
how could you possibly expect to do that
okay so here's David our lovely
co-collaborator tonight so here he is at
2 billion seconds old I think that's
roughly correct you guys can figure out
how old that makes him and more human
terms now imagine trying to do this
looking at a picture of him and
inferring what his blastocyst looked
like I think he looks like his mother
there but um this is only a factor of 2
million extrapolation This Is 50 orders
of magnitude 46 orders of magnitude more
and and yet we we think that we can do
such a thing and that has to do with the
Simplicity although it's complicated the
Simplicity the elementary nature of
space-time at very very early epochs
when the universe produced the CMB
radiation that we see so how do you do
that well it starts with a pairing of
theorists and experimentalists thinking
about ways that you could observe
directly the signature of inflation so
what inflation predicts is that there's
a background just like there's a
background of light there's a background
of gravitational waves they come through
space-time and they shake it and shudder
it and it causes Tremors and
reverberations those induce a specific
kind of swirling Motion in the uh in the
polarization patterns that we see in the
Big Bang that's called B mode
polarization for cognizante it's it's an
analogy to the magnetic field which is
written as a certain Vector operation so
we attempt to measure these little
polarization orientations and their
intensity on the entire sky or at least
on this patch of sky that we can observe
and The Smoking Gun has been called many
times to observe this pattern this is a
simulation and I'll show you later some
real data and you can compare for
yourself so how do we do that we set out
we built an experiment called bicep one
and then we built the success are called
bicep 2 including the very hard work of
my graduate student John Kaufman who's
in the audience who just became Dr John
Kaufman uh this is a telescope which is
not only uh one of the world's most
powerful telescopes it's also the
world's most southern telescope and the
coldest telescope in the known universe
and I'll explain why that is in just a
bit here it is if you ever see this
picture you're in really bad shape
because this is sunset at the South Pole
which happens once per year uh in March
in the in the uh towards the end of
March when spring starts for us that's
when fall starts at the South Pole so
you won't be getting out anytime soon if
you see this beautiful sunset it's a
relatively large collaboration although
not compared to say a particle
accelerator
about 12 or 15 different institutions
and we built this experiment we start
with bicep one in 2005 and we upgraded
bicep two and we have many more upgrades
still to come this is what the telescope
looks like before it was shipped down to
the South Pole it's a refracting
telescope it's actually not that big
this length here is about five feet long
but the unique thing about this
telescope is that we design it to be
cooled down almost to the temperature in
fact to the temperature of the cosmic
background radiation itself so it sits
at three degrees Kelvin the warmest
parts of it are at three degrees Kelvin
it sits on an ordinary telescope Mound
it can scan back and forth look up and
down quite simple
if you did a cross section through it
you'd see at least in the original
design it stands for background Imaging
of cosmic extra Galactic polarization
light comes in it's a refracting
telescope like Galileo used to First
change Mankind's conception of what the
universe was like
405 years ago with the training of his
small refracting telescope on on Jupiter
and on the moon so light comes in gets
focused on detector the detector arrays
sit at sit at a quarter of a degree
above absolute zero so these are cooled
down to 453 degrees Fahrenheit sounds
really cold and in fact it is
uh people wonder what the lenses are
made out of it's very simple we use a
very high Purity version of what we used
to have in these old milk jugs I don't
know if I've never seen one in
California maybe they're banned but uh
but that's just high density
polyethylene it makes a good lens it's
transparent for microwaves and it
induces almost negligible polarization
contamination
so now where would you put such a
telescope well here's the Palomar
Observatory so if you converted before 2
billion seconds into years you can
calculate what year David was born and
I'll just tell you that he was born so
they built this telescope for David this
was built the year before he was born so
that he could use it to think about the
universe as he's done uh throughout his
career this telescope though was built
and put in uh north of Julian and that
was done so for a reason because in 1949
that part of the of San Diego was quite
dark and its background what it's
looking for is light so he had to put it
somewhere dark we wanted to put our
telescope somewhere cold because we're
looking for something that is analogous
to heat so we want to take it somewhere
cold so we took it to Antarctica
and if you go out into space you can
look and look at an article like this
and the center of the Earth's axis the
southern point on the Earth's axis of
rotation is the South Pole and it's a
continent Antarctica is an actual
continent I actually brought some pieces
of it home with me the second time I was
there don't tell the governor no there
is no Governor there it's a lawless
continent there's only about 1200 people
there at any given time in the summer
and right now in the winter there's
about 200 people so the entire continent
is popular with 200 people so you can
actually get to a lot of superlatives I
was thinking when I was down there I
mean I've never been like you know it's
hard to be like the fattest person on
the North American continent but I could
actually do it in Antarctica I could be
the fattest part could be you could be
the shortest the tallest the oldest the
youngest uh see there's a continent of
superlatives including the fact that
it's the highest continent it's the
coldest continent it's the windiest
continent the South Pole sits at about 9
000 feet above sea level so it's a
little bit of the way into space where
you'd like to be ideally if you go uh to
this website in the summertime you'll
see a picture that looks like this right
now it'll be completely dark but there
is a webcam that shows you what the
weather conditions are like and it's
usually 100 chance of white and if you
think about it like a snow forecast this
is 9 000 foot deep base if you think
about skiing okay but unfortunately it's
all flat so you can't really get too far
you can go cross-country skiing we go
there despite the fact that there are
very known to be a very hostile natives
that live there despite that fact we
still went there so so it's very
dangerous environment but
some of my colleagues are here they
treat me worse than that okay so when
you go down there there's no Walmarts
there's no targets you can't buy clothes
when you're down there really besides
souvenir t-shirts to give to your
friends uh so instead you have to stock
up with all the clothing you're going to
use for the next month two months nine
months or a year you pack them into
these bags and you take all these
articles of clothing including these
really cool uh semi-inflated Moon boots
we call them so that you won't get
frostbite if you wear normal sneakers
your feet will freeze due to the
conductivity through the rubber
uh you catch a flight hopefully if you
wake up in the morning at five in the
morning in New Zealand uh you don't go
outside and see this but the first time
I went down I did this is a C-130 cargo
plane that flies from Christchurch New
Zealand to the McMurdo Continental base
in the U.S this is also one tenth of the
New Zealand Air Force it's pretty
interesting okay you sit there it's a
beautifully very spacious lots of
legroom no it's terrible environment to
be on if you notice there are very few
Windows if any the pilots have Windows
thankfully but there's only two or three
other windows on the whole plane there's
no bathroom on the plane you have a
little pot uh called The Honey Bucket uh
don't ask me why they call it that and
you're you're served you know your first
class meal is in a bag of some mystery
meat
and you sit knee to knee for uh luckily
it's only about 11 hours okay so uh but
you build up a lot of Frequent Flyer
points uh and eventually when you end up
getting to the South Pole the South Pole
is quite a beautiful place to to be at
least the first day you're there then it
gets kind of anonymous some people love
it John Calvin he loves it I get tired
of it you land here's the Passenger
Terminal okay this is the Admirals Club
presidents Club over here if you pick up
your life remember what this looks like
because you might see a picture of it
later on okay when the early original
explorers got there 102 years ago they
they skied up from sea level to 10 000
feet almost over waves of frozen snow
called sastrugi and as I said up above
crevasses and terrible terrible
environment we make it there in three
hours from the coast even on the c-130s
and if this is a sort of scale model of
what they would have looked like in
Photoshop they weren't so happy and in
fact Robert Falcon Scott said great God
this is an awful place and he little
didn't know he would die two months
later trying to get back from the South
Pole to his Fuel and food Depots
nowadays I say it's an awesome place so
this is the actual Act access on which
the Earth is turning pretty cool so I
can run around the world
and even for somebody slow like me you
can do it pretty quickly but I say it's
an awesome place because nowadays it has
a kitchen a greenhouse libraries a sauna
can you believe it a basketball half
size basketball court and many many
other amenities you have to prove to
your mother that you made it there so
you take a you take a selfie and you
start walking to work and there's bicep
so we built this Observatory back in
2005 and here's the outhouse
and this Outhouse if you remember what
the Passenger Terminal looked like is
very very reminiscent of what the
passenger term would look like I'm
always hoping they get that right this
is a site that also means they're going
to spend the winter there this means the
Sun is going down the sun doesn't go
straight down like it does here roughly
at some steep angle just grazes the
Horizon in fact you don't know where
it's going to go down when you're down
there so just circles around you can
barely see a tinge of green not from the
laser pointer but you can actually see
the Green Flash for over several hours
when you're down there this was taken by
our winter over the first season denim
arcats I always tell people they're like
well what's it like to be there and I
say it's great the pay is awesome you
get 75 000 and all you have to do is
work one night
there's the sun going down
okay so what happened what did we
actually observe well remember this
prediction this is a simulation one of
the nice things about making a big
Discovery potentially like this is that
you get places like the Washington Post
to do your graphic arts so they did a
simulation this pattern taken of what
you'd see if there were gravitational
waves and here in fact is real data this
is not a simulation we can compare the
predictions to what a simulation very
detailed simulation would predict and it
shows exact exact agreement so we have a
great confidence in it and and moreover
the scientific Community has spent many
many months just three months we've had
over uh over 600 different Publications
here's just this mattering of them uh
incl as of last night there's 600
Publications that are citing our results
dissecting it this is what scientists do
they have to check and closely observe
and make sure that they can confirm and
reproduce your results otherwise it's
not scientific
so here are the results uh the most
gratifying thing was this article in the
best science news journal there is the
onion it said stop theoretical physicist
R B singers meet to debate the meaning
of forever so down here it says we can
observe long-term phenomena like the CMB
primordial B mode polarization and the
love between India Arie and her man
all of which seem to have existed since
the universe's infancy and I want to
make them change it to R and B modes
because that's okay so when you go back
to this we think that we've observed
this imprint of gravitational waves
produced by inflation so if there was an
inflationary Epoch what does that imply
well it implies as Andy said perhaps
there's just Infinity of universes
called the Multiverse there's no not
necessarily a proof of it but if this
can be confirmed it would be very strong
motivation that perhaps something like
the Multiverse isn't too crazy
just finish up with a couple questions
um that I will want to ask David and
Andy later on if you guys don't ask so
what can you say about religion this
quote from Paul Davies is quite
evocative I'll just get cut to the point
he says that the Multiverse at a certain
level seems to be at least in the
anthropic or finely tuned versions seems
to be reminiscent of religion not as a
pejorative but just seems to be
philosophically
at least isomorphic in some sense to a
religious Theory or to a religious
concept rather not a theory so this is a
very interesting article that I
encourage people to read getting back to
Galileo what can we say about the God
and the universe so I just say stay
tuned if he had a big bicep perhaps he
wouldn't have faced the Inquisition like
this and uh thank you very much and see
you in November hopefully
[Applause]
so David will now present
and then after David's talk we'll have a
short q a period up in the front
so please keep your questions for that
okay
well um yes
so uh yeah this is a very very exciting
um I tried to ask Sheldon to put the
word out through David Kirsch and others
to see if we can get some of the members
of the artistic Community here at UCSD
to come and I'll explain an ulterior
motive later are any of you part of that
community
well I'm hoping I'm hoping there's some
of you here because we have an ulterior
ulterior motive for giving this talk and
I'll explain it a bit
um now
I've been giving a lot of talks about
seti the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence I'm on a lot of the
commissions and this next February Jill
Tarter who was here for one of our
wonderful movie nights
um uh on a panel discussion I shared
with her on the movie uh contact
she is hosting we managed to talk the
American Association for the advancement
of science the aaas to hold a special
session on seti and meti it's next
February in um in San Jose where seti is
the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence and Matty is messaging two
extraterrestrial intelligence something
that I as a science fiction author and
as an astronomer have been in opposition
to because
um it's quiet out there maybe too quiet
and if they're being quiet maybe they
know something we don't know
in any in any event we have been
learning so much about the universe just
in the last 15 years 15 years ago
we knew of no planets outside of our
solar system none
now we know of thousands
thousands
and you're a member of a civilization
that's been doing that
uh and soon we'll be launching uh new
follow-ups to the Kepler mission that
will raise that to the tens of thousands
possibly hundreds of thousands
in which case we're going to get a
better statistical notion of what the
universe is like and create the
conditions for a lot of great new ideas
for those of you out here who are the
brilliant Clarion kids who are going to
be taking over from us old fart
whippersnappers in the field of science
fiction
now in addition why do we want to care
about that why do we want to look around
there as Ken Ham the famous creationists
said aren't they all damned aren't all
the aliens damned anyway
if you look it up it's amazing just it
was in the news the last day or so
one of the reasons we
tribes in
scared most of the time they had good
reason to be and when the fear level is
high Your Horizon of Tolerance who you
would include call a fellow human being
include next to the camp fire allow to
speak at your councils was close in
that's the way we are
fear levels go down it doesn't
necessarily mean your horizons move out
but if you start with an outward looking
spirit
like we tend to have in our our culture
in our civilization then satiability and
low fear levels makes us look outward
and we look outward and outward and
outward and some of the fight over
inclusion is part of our politics today
our political Wars but if we don't find
aliens then guess what we'll make them
we already do it all the time
have any of you had children
every generation is invaded by a new
wave of Barbarians
and you know this
but in addition to that look at the
possibilities making artificial
intelligence many people are confident
that we'll reach that point in the next
40 50 years whether it's benign and
friendly like in the movie her or
vicious and
and
dangerous like in every other Hollywood
film
because out of laziness it's just easier
to create a dystopia and then your
protagonists can go run around shooting
things
or you know the whole question of robots
or is in some of my science fiction
stories
um the uplifting of creatures that are
very close to us in intelligence helping
them to go the last step past the glass
ceiling that seems to trap dozens and
dozens of other species the Clark Center
ran a wonderful event last May with the
Smithsonian back at the Reagan Center in
Washington DC in May and one of my talk
the talk I gave there is about this
whole question of otherness and whether
or not we're going to expand well our
our Notions this is just nothing this is
nothing
compared to the expansion that's been
going on in the notion of
the Multiverse the universe
so many things have changed in our
concepts of the universe just since the
turn of the century I mentioned that 15
years ago we knew of no planets outside
our solar system now it's thousands
well if you had talked about the
inflation and the creation of the
universe 15 years ago to almost any
physicist certainly 20 years ago
the notion of inflation was around the
notion of a big bang has been around for
quite some time
but almost any cosmologist would have
gotten angry and left the room at just
the things that were being discussed on
the screen today and today those same
cosmologists would happily discuss all
these things and claim that they never
would have gotten mad
how many of you remember that before
1999 you talked to any cosmologist the
Big Bang is not an explosion and it's
not set in anything
it is an expansion of the creation of
what is and the expansion of what is the
metric or the measuring sticks
how many remember the blowing up of a
balloon as being the metaphor
where everything's getting farther apart
from everything else
but there is no outside
and that's all there is
I think one of the most mind-boggling
things to me is the agility of physics
that that several of my friends who are
physicists almost deny ever having said
this
that there's nothing else this is all
it's all self-contained and now what do
we have we have the richness of concepts
of a context within which the balloon is
taking place it's not that the balloon
description was wrong
that is what's happening
but it may indeed have been an explosion
into a pre-existing space
and as mind-boggling as it is to me all
of these thoughts it's also
mind-boggling that we should always
remain agile
and so the first of these theories was
exploding
of the Multiverse is we have an
explosion into an already existing
infinite expanse of three-dimensional
space
absolutely stupid to to a cosmologist 20
years ago but that's now one of the
possibilities that there was a
pre-existing Infinite Space and these
are just bubbles opening up into it
and it didn't have to happen because of
inflation causes inflation it could have
been just a variation in Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle
that all of a sudden Delta e the energy
was infinitely available to be borrowed
from
now there's also the notion that this
Infinite Space
is a context within which you have this
inflation
and if it is then it's likely there's
other inflationary episodes next to it
and suddenly you have the manufacturing
of fresh space the manufacturing of
metric
and this feeds on itself and I just
don't have time to talk about it and
that's my excuse for not talking about
it rather than the fact that even though
I have a PhD in physics these guys are
out of my league
could not parse these equations if my
life depended on it
the question of whether or not in some
of these bubbles not only the initial
conditions as Andy spoke of would be
different but the physical laws would be
the same therefore you'd have galaxies
they just wouldn't include us they'd be
different
but also in different
bubbles they might have different
physical laws
The Staggering fact of our
bubble
the most amazing of all the physical
laws was the one finally parsed by
Einstein and of all the Brilliant Minds
of his time none of them actually
thought it out
we're used to thinking that time is the
standard against which all things are
measured
but time isn't
the standard invariant is the speed of
light and time can vary around it
I've thought about that a lot I haven't
a clue what that means
I can show you equations
maybe in one of these other universes it
makes sense
now here is something that is really
amazing and that is can we measure any
of these things the theological question
of whether or not this makes any sense
but because
if all of these universes are
permanently Out Of Reach
then isn't this just
tossing things around in the air isn't
it just
science fiction
because I create universes all the time
so do some of you
but in fact there are a few
possibilities and one is searching the
microwave background radiation for the
tiniest
images that might be appearing on our
bubble if it contacted another bubble
and this you can intuitively see bubbles
contact bubbles what do you get you get
a ring
and so searches are going on right now
one thing we do know is that if there
are any any such Clues they're extremely
small because we haven't found them yet
well there are other possibilities and
one is that singularities make universes
now this is mind-blowing and they've
actually known about this for quite some
time Hawking and all that they were
talking about this back around 1990 even
back in the 1980s and that is the notion
that when you have a very very large
star
it explodes as a supernova The Remnant
is converges into a black hole
and this folding of the metric in space
and the matter that pours into it might
result in the creation of a singularity
that has you saw some illustrations in
Andy's talk of a white hole that then
creates its own big bang and it does not
have to be a big bang of the same
magnitude of mass
as fell into it then you just get the
mass of a star or the case of the center
of our galaxy the mass of you know a few
hundred million stars
no you could in theory create a whole
new universe and it is detached from
ours
in ways that are kind of mathematically
mind-boggling but that the the brainiacs
thinkers highly plausible and this new
universe takes off
so that every time you form a black hole
you form a new universe and I'm going to
point out here that the
where is the turn
button
uh
it's on the tape oh there it is okay
well now this is that threshold that
they were talking about
and the photons that you see when you
measure the Three Degree background
radiation they are the original photons
that escaped when height when the
electrons all over the universe at 380
thousand
um years after the bang
suddenly it was cool enough for the
electrons to fall down become in orbit
around hydrogen around protons and
suddenly the universe became transparent
and these are the original photons from
that time
and there were are presumably no photons
from before that time because they were
constantly hitting free electrons
but it's the imprint of gravity waves on
this that Brian Keating was talking
about and that takes you back here
okay so you have this black hole that
may create a new universe somewhere else
okay
now the fun begins because there are all
sorts of possibilities for instance the
possibility that all sorts of new
singularities are created
where's the room for them
that's where your other dimensions come
in and Andy spoke of the possibility
that I wrote a short story about called
what continues
that is just incredible that Lee smolen
came up with and that is
that if black holes now try to follow
this if black holes create new universes
all right then a universe that creates a
lot of black holes
is creating a lot of daughters
now all you have to do is add a couple
more features to that the physical laws
of a universe are like its DNA
so if the baby universe is inherent the
physical laws
that allow stars to form and all that so
so that you make black holes then
they'll have more babies
all you need is one thing a little
variation in those laws what have you
got somebody
evolution
in other words those universes whose
physical laws are just right so that you
it makes a lot of black holes will have
a lot of babies
if their babies inherit this trait
those whose variance
made it even better for making black
holes we'll have more babies than those
who didn't
you evolve universes
toward the laws that will make more baby
universes are is your mind blown
this is so cool now there has been an
argument against this in that you could
imagine physical laws that would make
black holes a lot more likely why make
galaxies
because 99 of the Stars don't make
supernovas and don't make black holes
and I thought about an answer to that
and that is
that maybe it's not just black holes
maybe the black holes have to be tuned
somehow
maybe you need intelligent life
in which case the parameters are not
optimized just for making black holes
then the parameters are optimized for us
well it's an interesting Concept in any
event there's more
oh yeah that was going to yeah I was
going to talk about evolution
yeah the evolution to the ability of us
to be able to tune the process of making
black holes here's another one
are we all holy grams
well mathematically just in the last 15
years it's been figured out it's about
15 years isn't it since this result
mathematical boy the turn of the century
was really something
way back in those days the whole notion
that you can mathematically connect our
three-dimensional universe and all of
its atoms and all of its quarks
to the surface of a singularity like a
black hole
which means that the Hologram that's on
a surface
surrounding
an area of space
could be all there is
because that's all you need to describe
all of the things going on we all may be
maybe two-dimensional Holograms
and I don't know where to take that
but some of you Clarion kids might
watch um uh Brian Green's the elegant
Universe you've seen some of these
illustrations the notion in string
theory that our universe may be this
slab
in many dimensions but the parallel the
metaphor is that it's you know
two-dimensional slab you know containing
all the vibrations in all of our
galaxies and there could be stacked next
to each other
like sliced bread
in which case
the notion is
that
this explains why gravity is so weak
because gravity is the force that
actually can escape from the brain
whereas electromagnetism is constrained
to the brain and it can stain
constrained to our three dimensions
but here's the here's the interesting
thing if you have a whole lot of these
brains then
the notion is that some people feel is
that if if two brains connect and and
slam into each other it creates a new
Big Bang that fly sends them apart again
and then in one of in both of those
brains you have a new Big Bang that
describes destroys everything that's
there now that's that's kind of
disturbing at any given moment the brain
next to our brain which we cannot detect
heck I can hardly detect my own brain uh
may may collide with our universe and
end everything and have another big bang
well that's kind of disturbing
um I don't think so but in any event
then you have Quantum Andy talked about
this he showed this slide of
schrodiger's cat where in one uh reel
the uh Radioactive particles Decay and
release poison and the cat is dead in
Another Universe the radioactive
particle does not release the poison the
cat is alive I think there's always a
third
um in which the cat is extremely pissed
off
but this is the notion that we make life
decisions and if only I had made my life
decision otherwise I would be happy with
kids
just go ahead and have kids and see how
you feel about that but yes yes uh all
the possibilities that Branch off and
some wonderful sci-fi uh stories have
been written about the branch many ways
that this could Branch off for instance
Larry Nevins all the Myriad ways and
Robert sheckley's the store of the
Worlds
uh I want to get to the art now for just
a second
because
what wonderful wonderful theatrical art
could be made with the just
dramatization on stage
of the meeting
of two different versions of yourself
the different versions of what you might
have been
we could if we could find somebody who
looks a lot like Sheldon we could
actually have Sheldon come out with no
shirt
and and then uh someone else who looks
like Jesus saying
um
saying uh boy you know if I had time you
must not be a success because you've had
time to to work out
um here's another set of twins somebody
some of you may may recognize these twin
brothers
um the Benford boys
Greg and Jim they're mirror twins one is
Left-Handed one is right-handed one has
a mole on the left side one has a mole
on the right side one of them became a
theoretical plasma physicist uh in the
universities the other became a
theoretical plasma physicist and
Industry
so you see there's Divergence but the
question of
what else might I have been
what a wonder what isn't this a
fundamental human theme and archetype
and this is one of the reasons why I'm
putting out a call for San Diego sets of
identical twins
because they were the perfect actors who
for any of you who are playwrights who
might like to work with the three of us
and our aim is to try to come up with I
think it's November is it or or sometime
this winter maybe next spring some kind
of dramatization that would include
music or dance
or any of the Arts on this one of the
most spectacular of all themes the
question of multiplicity of paths the
multiplicity of possibilities
uh as as the poet once said
um I the Less Traveled path took and
that made all the difference
and then there's the question of
simulation
are we in the simulation
well that's the last of the categories
of possible alternate worlds
and it's hit into the big time in sci-fi
the whole Matrix notion the notion that
what you're seeing around you is is is
uh is not real
um it's it's a basis for the god-like
power that our children get from all the
games they play
where they get to experience what
previously was only experienced by crazy
people
um uh Street Corner preachers and sci-fi
authors and that is the ability to be
the creator of a whole universe
well the question then is
are what's what's how do you know we're
not in a simulation
and many of us have been writing science
fiction about this lately I have at
least half a dozen short stories dealing
with the question and some of them
available on my website
um the question of
how do you know how do you know that
you're not in a simulation right now
well there are a few pieces of evidence
that suggest that we are
if you were making a simulated Universe
you would want to save on your
computational power
so one way of making sure that you save
on your computational power is to make
sure that yours
civilization doesn't have doesn't deal
with other species in other planets and
other worlds because that would have
more to have to simulate
if you're going to simulate Humanity you
want them cut off as we are cut off
from the aliens that we think ought to
be out there
so what you do is you'd make the
distance between Stars really large and
you'd have an upper speed limit
called the speed of light
and that would save you vast amounts of
computational power another is you'd
have an absolute lower limit to the size
and that you can measure
the uncertainty principle
and that way you save on computational
power also by the fineness of your mesh
you'd have a bottom temperature
huh
there are lots and lots of weird aspects
to our universe that make it make it
seem as if it might be
but in beyond that what if we could
physically make universes
now you're talking the arrogance of
Western Civilization take it to its
limit and yet there are religions on
this planet
that believe that co-creation is part of
why we were made it's why God in the
only pure moment in the Bible
ask Adam to name all the beasts
an act of co-creation it's why in the
Tower of Babel story God says extremely
clearly nothing is beyond them
and if you look to the Baha'i people and
Mormons
this is a Perfectly Natural part
of growing up
that that this is what this is what
people do this is what the Creations do
is that they become creators and there
are some in the talmudic Jewish
tradition who also believe this
so I just want to finish
by saying
that
um saying up yours to Walt Whitman
he wrote a poem that was one of the most
scurrilous and nasty and awful things
ever written and that was the Learned
astronomer did anybody ever know that
one
where he attends a lecture by astronomer
an astronomer and he becomes sinks into
a deep depression over the charts and
the experimental results and he goes
outside and feels better by smugly
knowing how much better he is than the
astronomer because he looks up at the
stars in wonder
that's called the zero-sum game
in order to achieve the Wonders that
things like that Brian and his
colleagues are achieving and Andy
we have to surrender something else
but that's not the proper American
attitude
at least
the proper human attitude which is a
positive sum game
I can have it all
by understanding the universe better
we can appreciate it better
how many of you feel listening to the
three of us that we have lost our sense
of wonder
our sense of the ability to appreciate
the beauty in a rainbow all we're doing
is looking at more rainbow
you are the kind of people I don't have
to lecture you about this you're the
kind of people who came here tonight
and that's really in all the cosmoses
the multiple layers of
World Cosmos universes of universes
that's the Wonder
you thanks
[Applause]
ah maybe we'll address that to Andy
yeah can you hear me
um the the idea is this this is August
part of the same larger space
so that there's a sense in which these
universes even though they're so far
away that we couldn't access them if we
travel the speed of light forever
according to relativity they're still
connected they're still part of the same
larger space
and and the idea is that we're still
talking about the same laws of physics
so quantum mechanics the same physics
that governs inflation
would be in place in between these
different bubble universes and that uh
the but but in each of them observers
from the inside after inflation stops
would see what looks like a normal kind
of expanding Universe like we see and uh
the parameters of nature could be
different in each of these bubbles but
the idea is that the laws of physics you
can distinguish between the laws of
physics which is what the equations look
like and then the parameters things like
these dimensionless constants of nature
like the the mass ratio of the proton
electron those kinds of things could be
different
yeah the the notion of of an underlying
context of laws Within
would say for instance this Evolution
has taken place back 20 years ago I was
asking this question you know of some of
the some of the physicists who were
still saying the balloon expanding
balloon is all there is and the laws all
began at that first moment when it all
emerged out of a fluctuation in
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle and I
said yes but in which context was there
a Heisenberg's uncertainty principle
and now the notion is that there are
some things that pervade whatever meta
space is there
that allow then each Cosmos to have its
own details
uh okay thank you guys so where's the
microphone next to okay
oh Brian you've
talked about discoveries of empirical
evidence through cosmic background
radiation gravitational waves of the Big
Bang
what
physical evidence might we achieve
someday
to demonstrate the reality of
multiverses
yeah so there are different classes so
the question was what other types of
empirical evidence might prove or
motivate the fact that there might be
indeed a Multiverse so there are
different levels of of predictions and
models that predict uh startlingly
obvious signatures
um uh David actually showed one where
you have these two circles on the sky in
opposite places and people have looked
for that uh those signatures in the in
the cosmic background radiation as well
seeking to to perhaps detect the
collision between two of these baby
universes within the Multiverse so
that's that's perhaps one of the most
obvious ones then there are different
levels of credulity if you're willing to
accept the notion that a discovery of
gravitational waves proves or motivates
inflation and that inflation must be
difficult if not impossible to stop that
it must be going on everywhere so even
though we might not detect these other
universes uh similarly we we believed
100 years ago that Adam you know where
the most finely grained substance that
we could possibly detect and observe in
the laws of nature were as we knew it
back then now we know much more so I
think we'll winnow down the
possibilities first and then what can
delve into potential other observable
signatures but I should say that it's
it's motivated equally well from
inflation Theory and string theory and I
don't know of a way observationally to
prove it from the string theory side
there there are some ideas very
speculative in these versions of string
theory where you have these large extra
Dimensions like these brain world
scenarios that David was mentioning
um we have some evidence that's very you
know intriguing this is the idea of
so-called Dark Matter uh it seems like
there's a lot of missing mass in the
universe and some people speculate that
one way of explaining this is that it
could be due to the gravitational
influences of other brains farther away
I don't know if this is correct but
that's the kind of a thing where maybe
there actually already is evidence out
there for other universes and we just
need the theoretical and philosophical
framework in order to really elucidate
that yeah I think the notion that there
might be brains next to ours we already
have as one of the theories that gravity
go can leave the our brain whereas some
other forces can't in which case we
might be feeling
another brain above another below and
wouldn't they cluster their galaxies
near ours too by the gravitational
influence and this would explain some of
the effects that we see in our Galactic
rotation if I might also add those of
you who are artists I didn't mention it
if you're interested in pursuing any of
these ideas for
possible performance art about the
Multiverse get in touch with Sheldon
brown or any of us care of the Clark
Center yeah great
uh can we move the microphone around
throughout the room please
okay uh
start over there yep
hi and thank you very much I thought
this was all fascinating I have a
question
um I I've been studying this for about
30 years and I'm just wondering if any
or all of you may have looked at this
from a slightly different direction
which is basically from the direction of
the golden ratio the Fibonacci sequence
having looked into that I found it
fascinating that just about everything
that's considered beautiful or balanced
is based on that ratio about 1.61
something and the more I looked into it
whether it's the arrangement of the
pistols of a sunflower or the curvature
of the Nautilus see Nautilus or the
curvature of the human ear or the spiral
nebula that you look into in where the
curvature of a wave all is built on this
same ratio throughout nature and I think
in 2003 which is where I'm going with
this if I'm not mistaken French
cosmologists
had deduced that the actual shape of the
universe was a dodecahedron which again
is built on this same ratio which you
would think is an artificial shape so in
getting into Multiverse Theory I'm
wondering if you've looked at that that
ratio what it roll it could play in all
of this and having a descriptor for what
this all looks like and how it fits
together
I have not looked at that I don't know
have you guys looked into that well it
occurs to me that we like it in part
because we're constantly perceiving us
around us and that natural phenomena
that add our additive processes like the
creation of crystals the creation of
branches on a tree
that these would tend to follow a
Fibonacci Sequence if they're adding in
a relatively
moderate way
so it may be just it's just the matter
that when Nature adds things to adding
things to adding things
that it occurs a lot and we find it
Pleasant because it means that whatever
is going on is healthy
that's just a speculation that's just a
Sci-Fi and one quick follow-up question
to that is that I don't know if any of
you have seen the I think it's a
somewhat famous picture on the internet
but they did a slice of a mouse's brain
and illuminated it and then they
overlaid a picture of the universe and
it was nearly identical
well one of the
one of the and if you look at the funnel
Singularity whole
that God is emerging from with his
cherubs with his hand to give the spark
of life to Adam
it's shaped exactly like a human brain
with the um with the filigrees coming
off exactly where the cerebellum is and
his hand coming straight out of the
prefrontal lobes interesting yeah my
student John Kaufman thank you for the
question my student John Kaufman is a is
a student of this type of Art in the
microwave background and he actually
found a picture a very distinct picture
of a rabbit in our data set it's quite
beautiful can we pass the microphone
around
Cosmic rabbit hole
maybe in the way back I see someone
who's had her hand up for a long time
so if there were specific requirements
in terms of the constants and the laws
of physics that were required for life
to begin in our universe
and there are also bubble other
multiverses where laws are different how
could other universes support life
maybe Andy you can address that so we we
really don't know very much as much as
we would like about How likely life is
to come into existence what we can say
are things that we think are crucial
prerequisites for our kind of life
and you can make some some pretty
plausible Arguments for what are the
kinds of prerequisites you need for life
in any case for example you can have
parameters like of cosmology where the
universe collapses after a fraction of a
second I don't think anything's gonna
happen very interesting there so so and
and you can have the university expand
and accelerate so fast that everything
just becomes empty
and all the matter is diluted I don't
think things are going to happen there
that are interesting so it could be that
that if you looked at this whole
Multiverse by by some measure most of
the universes are really uninteresting
from our perspective maybe most of them
don't have life at all and so this is
still an open question we actually
really don't know how to do statistics
especially
oh go ahead could there be other
um universes that don't necessarily
support life but have things like
similar solar systems planets stars in
the same kind of uh way that we do it's
certainly a possibility because we have
a real lack of knowledge here we know
things that are that are necessary
conditions for life like having a planet
but we don't know what the sufficient
conditions are so we don't know how
likely it is for life to start for
evolution to get going I I personally
think it's quite plausible that you
could have a universe with planets but
life didn't evolve it really depends on
the answer to open questions which we
don't understand about How likely it is
for self-replicating molecules to kind
of get going
yeah the uh what you're talking about to
some extent is What's called the
anthropic principle and that is it's no
coincidence that we observe that we're
in one of those universes that had the
conditions necessary and for for you to
have life
uh because nobody's in those other
universes to notice that they're in a
sterile universe
what the mind then starts doing is
saying what's the ratios
are there gazillions of sterile
universes for everyone that gets people
sitting on stage asking silly questions
about parallel universes that they're
never going to see anyway
well that's where Lisa Mullen comes in
because if there's evolvability of
universes and this multiplicity of
universes
uh are not the laws aren't random
but they're inherited and refined by
Evolution then the vast majority of our
sister universes
have beckoned life in them and a
majority of them have
at least some bipeds
in auditoriums
talking about this
and if you spursed it out
I've lost the Infinite Space
some of those by heads will be me
wearing mostly black
and um
and answering questions from somebody
wearing white
I can't uh maybe we'll move it up uh
somewhere in the middle there but I
can't stress enough no matter how long
our universe may last our Multiverse we
must keep paying your taxes I think
right over there
yes I want to say something about the
anthropic principle it's always
described in terms of very narrow
uh tolerances on any one parameter
but Victor stenger among other people
have shown that a few very several
parameters at once you may get very
strange universes but they still have
complex matter or should
and also there's actually another paper
out with uh describing a possible
Universe with complex matter and there's
therefore possibly life that doesn't
even have a weak nuclear force
so I think that the range of variation
is really much wider than most people
think well even if you have a lot of
even if you have a universe where it's
hard to have a
Goldilocks zone these Goldilocks zones
that Andy showed you know around around
Stars perfect for water on the surface
of the planet we now realize that it's
highly likely that there are oceans
still in the universe covered with ice
worlds like Europa Enceladus we now
believe that there are as many as it
doesn't
worlds in our solar system that could be
abodes for life because they have liquid
water under conditions that have some
energy
so even if the Earth weren't here which
means that almost all of the solar
systems probably have some
even if the star is not stable even if
there's no Goldilocks zone if if matter
condensed
and there's a snow
barrier in the end and there are ice
worlds there's probably something that
could have life in almost any solar
system
yeah this is a very very good question
because we don't know enough about the
the conditions that are necessary for
life to know whether or not there could
be other islands in the parameter space
of the Multiverse where we're very
different kinds of Life Could evolve
um I think we need to exercise do
humility here and recognize that we we
don't know what would happen if you
change multiple constants at the same
time people like Victor stenger and
others are just starting to think about
this it's definitely an open question
these are why these these questions are
so exciting there's so much more to do
of all the exciting photos that I've
seen the Viking Lander and so many
others from our space program the thing
that jazzed me the most was the image of
an ocean Shoreline clear River patterns
mountains
on Titan
the huygen space probe showed what it
clearly oceans of methane
and
gasoline and mountains made of wax
overlying ice
I mean if there are living beings there
they would be made of wax
and we some of you in this room
will live in a civilization that
actually goes there and finds out I'm
hoping almost all of us okay so maybe
we'll take uh one more this guy's had
his hand up yeah let's bring it up front
and then both him will finish up
all right so um talking about the um uh
universes inside black holes or being
created by black holes if that were the
case
um and our universe were inside a black
hole
um or any Universe like that
um wouldn't there continually be more
stuff in the universe like it would be
expanding but not only adding space but
but but matter as well as coming through
as well
yeah and you want to tackle that up it's
it's an interesting question what the
relationship is between the inside and
the outside
and there's a certain question it could
be very very much that we were kind of
screened off from anything that's
happening outside in in the cases where
Singularity is formed in a new sort of
universe you know pinches off
the the relationship between the parent
and child might might end
um so in that case you might not be
dealing with an influx of new new matter
um let's say there are other more
complicated ways that space-time can be
intersecting like wormholes
um it very well may be that if stable
wormholes exist then indeed you could
see an influx of matter going through
from a distant part in space and time
and you know if you're asking the
question about our universe
um we certainly don't see evidence of of
giant agglomerations of matter appearing
out of nowhere
um so you know maybe that uh maybe you
know if we're inside of a black hole
we're not necessarily you know at the
other end of a wormhole but these are
all very interesting open questions and
it's it's certainly a fun and exciting
thing to think about and it's actually
amazing that uh you you can think about
these things and then you think okay
wait wait a second how can we
experimentally test for the existence of
wormholes particles of matter would be
traveling in slightly different ways
around wormholes than around normal
black holes this is something that
astronomers might eventually be able to
detect and if those are detected Not
only would that be Nobel prize winning
it would be the kind of a thing that
would allow us to realize that some of
these places would seem inaccessible
forever are actually not necessarily in
principle and accessible I certainly
hope that the Universe ends up being a
place where the ideas we can think of
are also ideas that we can test and and
that that's an aesthetic bias I don't
know if that'll be borne out but it
certainly it certainly would be a little
a little bit more kind if the universe
wasn't playing a cruel joke on us that
we could think of these things so let's
all turn to the simulators who are
running this simulation
you know hey how about it here you know
I'll always turn always turn to the
third wall all the time because that way
you can tell the simulators
I know I know and we never got around
too much about theology but that's
another time so see you all on August
11th for the next sciflex movie and uh
next Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination event thank you all for
thank you thank you thank you very much
[Music]
yeah
it worked yeah a lot of fun that was
great it was terrific yeah
did you ever